well ryan police are still out here
right now investigating this deadly
crash the crime scene tape is also still
up it seems like this that local leaders
want to avoid and that's why one clark
county commissioner is trying to create
a brand new office to help keep our road
safe
it's horrendous it's terrible the number
of deadly crashes in southern nevada is
climbing at an alarming rate as of
monday night there have been 107 traffic
related deaths in metro's jurisdiction
this year compared to 101 in all of
2020. if we can reduce these numbers
even in a small way it has an enormous
impact on people's life that's why clark
county commissioner michael naft is
pushing to create the clark county
office of traffic safety it would
establish a director to work with other
county departments and outside agencies
to help protect the public whether it's
in the way our roads are engineered and
designed and built or whether it's in
enforcement on the tail end of that
another goal is to save money a cleanup
of a fatality while it's hard to talk
about it has an enormous price tag how
confident are you that this new position
will actually make a difference
i know it will
we went to charleston and land the scene
of a recent deadly crash to ask locals
if they think naft's proposed traffic
office would be effective yeah i think
it would be
because i think there's a lot of
careless drivers it shows that they're
involved
for pedestrians and drivers you know
it shows good faith a move naft calls
necessary we need to make sure that
we're not leaving any stone unturned
when it comes to saving lives
naf tells me the office of traffic
safety within clark county would also be
in charge of applying for federal grant
money to help keep our roads safer he'll
present his ideas to the commission at
tomorrow's meeting reporting live
tonight orco mana live local now